thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys what
we're currently off the Record and by
the way I like the amazing episodes
they're always really good yeah amazing
episodes they're amazing we try here I
was recently this weekend celebrating uh
my lady's birthday we were at a Big Bear
cabin and stuff like that and then
randomly uh one it's with her cohorts
which are all all women and stuff like
that randomly one of the ladies comes up
and goes like women
they're like hey if uh Anthony had the
chance one night with Beyonce would you
give him a hall pass Oh I thought she
was gonna be like hey Nina can we all
[__] Anthony right now since he's the
only guy here and we need dick
we need it now is that where you were
going that's what it sounded like man
that's the classic Anthony situation
wow that derailed me uh like I said
yeah they asked her hey uh if it was
Beyonce or not would you give him a hall
pass and she was like Beyonce she's like
yeah
then I was like whoa did you ask her why
yeah in Earnest she just said yeah she's
[__] around I don't know why did it
have to be it's a trap dude afterwards I
was like hey you're about to have Jay-Z
then if that's the case but the point is
Daisy is not really an even trade that's
not even hey even he's more Rich dude
but that money's not gone to her it's
just what about Chris Brown yeah yeah I
don't think he's gonna beat her up he's
gonna beat up her [__] though oh yeah
yeah I hope not yeah we're taking this
part but I like it so now what what did
she did you ask her why like because it
seems like it's like a reaction that was
like oh [__] I never thought you would
say something like that um well I mean I
think the idea of hall passes in general
is a very curious thing and anytime you
hypothetically think about it it's
always kind of like at what level at
what tier what person or in what
situation would a hall pass even be
warranted because that's I'm not the
type of person it's like thinking about
like dude who would I haul pass but yeah
and I don't want us all sound like a
bunch of dudes that are Degeneres and
thinking about all these chicks we want
to [__] and stuff so let's roll reverse
this is a trap this is good let's roll
reversal all I'm saying all I'm saying
is if all right in what situation uh if
your chick asks for a hall pass who
would you say okay to okay who would you
foreign
what if it was Jackson Wang yeah too
close to home oh you have to be a
stranger because they know they know
they're he's a kenja now what is that's
a crewmate who he was Donnie what if it
was like so questionable because you're
like wait wait wait you're attracted to
that like what if it was something like
Danny DeVito or something yeah would you
be insulted yeah why don't you want
Chris Pratt or something
what if it was like
it was like no Chevy oh if I'm gonna
give you a hot pass then it's Jason
Momoa you know or like something I want
residual dick [__] sweat from that
man I almost would rather have a Danny
DeVito because then to me it's almost as
if like oh like this is what you usually
like like you're like a teriyaki chicken
person every once in a while you want
some Boombah away but you're gonna go
back to teriyaki chicken
can you tell we're hungry you know what
I mean I might be like just for this
today's conversation if it was like
hypothetically damned if you don't I
think that would raise a lot more like
why yes and then I might also after said
let's say if I was rewarding her such
Hall Pass afterward I would I would just
constantly be like but why but is there
any existing celebrity or someone that
she actually does kind of like she
always says this to annoy me but she's
always a fan of Tom Holland and I'm like
I'm a [__] kid he's a kid he's
a little baby that's what I'm saying
baby man I get it I get it you know what
are you retaliate with yeah
oh you want to go on a kid touring
that's why I like yeah yeah that's a
trap what I'm trying to say I'm gonna
retaliate with you okay I'm gonna keep
it at Beyonce but you would want to [__]
Beyonce so what about you Steve who
would you know why are you asking us
this come on no no he's a trap this is a
trap this is the prom okay so now I'm
gonna say it's not okay to you now that
you said Beyonce and that's who you're
no no that was the hypothetical that
started this prompt which is why it's in
the subject matter now we're going to
move on to the next guests
again let's give up our guests
why did Beyonce come on all right so I
got a question you're gonna say okay for
Nikki
um I would well you know here's the
thing about me
um I would never do such a thing thank
you thank you are we doing that Anthony
thing where he goes and then we don't we
all don't go no no no no that's what I
was intimating wait I I I'm curious
about something because to me I'm
unsatisfied with the answer where you
asked you asked Nino why and then we
didn't get an answer we're not there
what this is a prompt it's not a story
[__] follow the host once okay
for two and a half minutes he's the one
who brought up Danny DeVito hello
all right thank you so Bart go ahead
okay save the [__] video go I'm gonna
go but also I'm in Joe's boat because I
think as the audience I know we're
supposed to follow the host I got your
back but as the audience there's [__]
hangings we're gonna let Geo Rail and
you're like wait but there's [__]
trumpets over here what what am I
listening that's what I'm saying
trumpets yeah yeah where's the real
goals I'll follow you I got your back
you know what [__] me up is because
Anthony goes Anthony goes and then I
asked her why and then and then he keeps
going and I'm like wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait exactly I never said and
then I asked her what was the story
you're literally writing [__] is and
then I asked
him give him a bone I'll go
um me or Gio like which one again if
everybody was paying attention not being
an idiot sorry the concept is who would
you let them [__] allow your girl to
hall pass so that we're not sitting here
talking about chicks we want to [__] for
me for me it's uh well let's do that
let's do that for me it's honestly
anybody anybody as long as it's Even
Stevens so even Steven if she can do it
then I can do it and it's more of uh I
because to me I'm like I know people
have multiple tastes right like you can
I just it's like they're getting a
different flavor so if you want a
different flavor than me I understand
I'm pretty realistic but I'm like as
long as our relationship stays balanced
then it's it's cool with me so if I had
to guess yeah she would probably like
Tom Hardy can you and I also agree he's
a hot man
Tom Hardy so what's the even to that
uh that's probably what who she's gonna
pick and who who what I like that what's
the even I like I like Rihanna okay oh
really I got a question
I like girls that have a Caribbean
accent yes
Barbados because I think she's super
sexy
if it's Even Stevens right yeah so if
Daddy come to you is her choice does
that mean that Roseanne would be the oh
yeah I don't know for me Even Stevens is
just
um they're twins obviously for me it's
just the the act of doing it
you know what I mean like like Hall Pass
has to go both ways just call pastors go
both ways she can go Danny DeVito she
can go Tom Hardy it's a blank uh I can
go Roseanne I can go Roseanne I can go
Rihanna it doesn't matter but to me the
relationship has to be the same I
thought it was actually attractive no no
no no no it's just the the rights I
guess so she can go Tom Hardy and you
can go Roseanne sure sure if that's what
you're into if I'm that's what I'm into
I'm more about the rights and the the
limits of the relationship rather than
like like that celebrities as trading
cards you know like this is worth five
Mana this is only four models
I heard even I heard even yeah yeah I
feel like you'd be pretty liberal with
All Passes
um I it's like giving them out
she has a hall pass right now but it's
who it's it's weird
that's not a hall pass that's not the
whole thing exactly that's your fantasy
that's every guy's bad exactly that's
why I don't care I'm like if you want to
flirt with girls have a girlfriend I
don't care then answer the question of a
dude who are you giving her not allowed
absolutely at all ever yeah no other
seamen can touch her it's a hypothetical
so me and Nikki have this thing we've
actually had this conversation many
times but for for me it's like so you
know I've done a bunch I did a bunch of
movies and stuff like that so I was like
man if I ever am in like the same room
as Helen Mirren what was that again
Helen Mirren interesting yeah big titty
old Fox when she was young she was a
falling Silver Fox she's a total Silver
Fox milfy what movie is she she's in a
lot of she's a ton she's in the red
movies she's like um yeah the one with
Bruce Willis Bruce Willis Morgan Freeman
but you know what I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna deflect here and if I had to do it
because I want to make her happy more
than my jealousy then
um I'd have to cook the situation
because one my curiosity will [__]
kill me I have to know if they [__]
better than me and two I want to watch I
want her to see me cry while they [__]
yeah yeah guilt her see how much you're
hurting me a [__] selfish [__] it's
hot you know what I mean and then
afterwards we can dramatically talk
about it and then ruin our relationship
you got to get one with our titties do
you think that for do you think uh or do
you care about the events
even to get a hall pass now and then now
you guys are back on the same page or no
maybe one day when we're not physically
attracted to each other there would be a
full hall pass on both sides and we can
[__] whoever we want
look we just gotta find a good one the
problem is when she was younger it's all
black and white wow really [__] wait
what are you looking at Helen Mirren
Helen mirror wait wait wait wait is that
your is that your is that your hot pass
it's a safe search is off Steve that's
who he wants yeah yeah 100 facts not
even a bit what era though any era I
don't know why she's so [__] hot
she's hot why is she still I wasn't
expecting that so you know that could
have happened right I'm doing major
Motion Pictures I'm making the thinning
I'm making the thinning too I'm making
you know and then Nikki's like well you
know I want my haul fast to be
you know someone in the poker community
and I'm like well of course Johnny Tran
that's easy
no so hers is Phil Hellmuth and mine is
is Helen Mirren and uh now she's Phil
Hellmuth constantly at parties with Phil
Hellmuth
I haven't made a movie in four years
oh and that's dangerous feeling good
about it I'm feeling good about it yeah
dude yeah real even Steven dude Phil
helmet does not threaten me though I'm
[__] kidding she's never that's not
what it is no hers is obviously Eminem
obviously oh right right right Nick
would you give a hall pass to your girl
for Bad Bunny you know what she says she
goes I'm actually not attracted to him
in any way I just really like his music
right she attracted to those Oh I
thought you meant the the girl back in
the day she used to love Paul Walker oh
okay she's still she's like he's the
finest white boy yeah but that pass is
pretty much not gonna happen well he's
got a brother does he oh really or they
used him for the the final shot they
deep faked him for a little bit she
loves Paul Walker but so let's say he's
still alive
would you let her if she gave you one
nah dude no you wouldn't let her no I I
I absolutely not let's say enough let me
let me ask you guys this right we're
still young there's a lot of sexual
jealousy imagine if you had multiple
kids and we're out like in our 50s now
and then he's just like man I just want
to get some [__] like
sex
double talk talk even more juveniles
can I get like yeah can you sex me like
you used to and she's like man I'm
[__] tired bro and it's like man I'm
tired too you know like she's here well
what's up we still horny
what if that conversation comes and
you're just like I want some young dick
I want some young ass [__] let's go
yeah how young age appropriate
all trap State age appropriate that's a
trap card but I mean think about it when
you're okay when you're 50 young pussy's
like 30. dude for me it's about it's I
am just too lame I think I just think
I'm too emotional honestly I am too I
love Nikki too much and um the idea of
her actually [__] on Eminem and then
actually happening I think I would be
[__] crushed I would I'm on Steve's
Court 100 what I couldn't handle it and
and and you know she's voice to me many
times and she doesn't actually want to
[__] him but that makes me think she
actually does want to [__] him and I'm
watching her oh yeah yeah same thing oh
she might totally be down dude you know
what I mean do you want to hear
something gay as [__] sure
um I think I'd be down uh I was way more
down for hall passes until tiger came
into the picture lame
a man what the [__]
edit that out it's gonna ruin his career
even with like the whole Kazumi
conversation about like you know like uh
open relationships and I was just like
whoa that was like a whole not even
entertaining it but just that was a
perspective I've never heard of before
so when I went home I was talking to Geo
about it and uh like going to a swingers
or like not just sharing the story not
having like an angle I'm secretly trying
to do hey what do you think
so what'd you think about that story
should I throw these tickets away or uh
sharing the story kind of liberating and
empowering to women don't you think
that's the best one
I was like sure and I was having my own
thoughts and I'm like if it's one of
those things where like if you've never
crossed the line you don't know what's
on the other side right so if I'm with
my woman
if I [__] someone else or had feelings
or even like text flirt with someone
else
I don't know what that leads to and I'm
in a different place and I don't know
how I view my woman or even my family
now and so to me that is so sacred right
now that it's like
as long as we have him I can't even
Envision any other dude I feel the same
way sometimes I get scared about that
[__] too it's like I feel like once you
start going on that path of like you
know [__] all these other chicks or
whatever if that's in your cards what a
path like yeah like this guy over here
you know or like gonna dominate your
destiny yeah exactly I feel like that's
a slippery slope and I know so many
people that have gone down the slope of
them like indulging in that like sexual
fantasy all the time where they can't
have necessarily like a normal life
because all they want to do is like I
gotta chase these [__] [__] everybody
my father fixes Peters right for Pewters
yeah Peters and he says that one of the
weirdest things that he encounters all
the time that makes him very thankful
for family and like the bond of marriage
and all that [__] is going to people's
houses who would have got divorced and
like just seeing how lonely they are oh
God that's what it is the pictures on
the walls and the like I'm alone in a
big [__] fat house and my kids don't
visit me anymore because I animosity yep
and there's tribes and all this [__] and
he just like his b always tells me how
Wild that is and like yeah I think the
grass is always greener right 100 just
the feeling of knowing that your ex is
trying to make your own kids hate you
all the time damn that's crazy man
that's God I was thinking of a damn
Bilzerian single life and you guys
[__] making it scary it's scary scary
look dude it looks like it's covered in
cotton candy and rainbows dude but it
tastes like [__]
because a lot of people don't have the
youth strength and money to live out
that Playboy life after your divorce
you're gonna throw your back out with
some [__] 22 year old later give me a
break that's why I really appreciate
like people like Kazumi who are so
blatantly surface level honest with what
they want rather than guys that try to
snake their way into getting that yeah
and then you get an unsanctioned hall
pass at the best of a woman's mentality
oh yeah like that's weird although
that's no way to do it in Kazumi
situation it sounds like she's more
comfortable than her man is he's pretty
cool yeah he gets his he gets his treats
she's like oh we need a dick who's got
some dick around here I do well me and
my porn star friends are gonna use your
dick right now again I guess I have to
can we hear the trumpets now so how did
you guys arrive at that conversation
yeah we all shared your turn now dude no
I don't know the girls are just talking
about it for whatever reason and why
Beyonce out of all the and why they talk
why they clear you about it yeah why is
it a sexy situation they were asking
everybody in the group and then they
eventually got to me no they asked they
didn't ask me to ask Nina you know what
I mean yeah and they named a random name
just be honest no they're asking all
everybody in that group it was just the
topic of conversation you know when
you're [__] randomly having a it's
like why the [__] does Danny DeVito come
up like that's just a conversation and
Men worship Danny in a video they're
having an all-girls JK news yeah you
know other people have fun talking about
random [__] and then did you like like
start shaking in deflect like you did in
this video
I can't wait to see Nikki [__] Eminem
you're not gonna see it because she'll
never do it she wouldn't do it to me
we'd have to watch through a deep fake
you [__] weirdo
I got the link right here
why would you want to see that come on
disgusting is it to an Eminem song
though
listen to his own music while he's
[__] that'd be a tough that'd be
crazy I think the fantasy is probably
just way more than the reality that's
what I think because when I I was I I
feel like the same way of like the Chase
and like actually getting the girl is
sometimes way more crazier than actually
having sex with them for the first time
because to me sex is better over time
when you get like build rapport this is
gonna sound super gay coming out of me
all right it's all good but when there's
love
when there's a connection and when you
have time to learn each other's bodies
and Things become more sensual but
that's less facts though I have the most
intense orgies or orgasms and I call
them orgasms did you say orgies I heard
that too I have the most intense orgies
dude in love Joe is a [__] trippy
thing to witness yeah I didn't I know
I'm growing guys
but I'm telling you I did it because I
come way [__] harder when I'm in love
that's tight that's right you know come
in to make a baby is pretty [__] cool
too really maybe I'll try it look at
this little space zoom in on that
because like when you and the guys know
one of those turns and you're like whoa
no because you know when you're when
you're like okay we're trying to make
one now yeah and then you like and
you're in a good spot in a relationship
you guys really love each other all that
all that history you're talking about
you know each other and you gotta have
awesome sex and then a beautiful
creature comes out of it it's the gayest
thing
trying to picture your future child
oh and you're like oh and you picture
flowers coming out of like wet Earth
wetter wet Earth that's tight that's a
great visual well people should come
less to on the chest and more inside the
[__] then I've always said that yeah
Joe's less [__] shots that are
ineffective yeah more cream pies to get
her pregnant proving why you're the
[__] King if you guys are ready for
it none of this applies though because
you guys are just [__] dudes because
you're both gay
serving up those Empires too as you know
he's going down there and getting him
right back out
[Laughter]
sick [__]
I'm not gonna be there for long